dramatic isn't how we describe mom to be
Megan Markel style during her and
Harry's royal tour of Australia why
because as it should be
her pregnancy style is all about
comforts the two paid a visit to a male
born beach today the Duchess donned a
trench coat over a black dress as they
met lifeguards ditching her usual
stilettos making more sensible and comfy
pair of flats as she walked in the sand
we got our best look at the Royal baby
bump yet as the Duchess changed into a
navy blue dress and tossed an Australian
football one young woman who had waited
hours to meet Harry just lost it when he
hugged her and she broke into a flood of
happy tears prepping for Parenthood
they're spending lots of time with young
kids
Harry was especially charmed by a small
baby and played with her feet one young
lad presented Megan with a homemade
pasta necklace he painted gold where the
two were asked about possible baby names
won't Megan replied quote we've been
given a long list of names from everyone
we're going to sit down and have a look
at them Megan is a self-professed foodie
and on a visit to a restaurants kitchen
she examined local ingredients taking a
sniff at an herb while Harry was the
official royal taste tester well I mean
Harry might not want to eat before his
next official stop because he is
climbing the famous Harbour Bridge in
Sydney 440 feet above water and get this
without that Kevin Frazier is gonna be
in Australia to see it all happens when
he joins the royal tour yes he will I
would like to see Kevin do that
[Music]
[Applause]